estas sentencias ya quedan definitivas
porque fue el fiscal general de parís
esta mañana quien comunicó que ninguno
de los de las catorce personas presentes
y que fueron condenadas a lo largo de
ese juicio pues se decidieron apelar a
la decisión se supo también esta mañana
por parte de un comunicado de los
abogados de salud de slam el principal
de estos acusados el principal además y
el único miembro de ese comando de que
se perpetró estos atentados y que está
con vida dijo que él no iba a apelar
esta decisión no porque esté de acuerdo
con ella sino porque ya se va a resignar
todo esto a pesar de que los abogados en
el comunicado hacen saber que no están
de acuerdo con la decisión de su cliente
pero que igual pues tienen que respetar
la decisión de su representado por parte
de ella de las familias de las víctimas
pues consideran que ya es una forma de
alivio y que ya pueden de alguna manera
ya pasar la página después de diez meses
bastante difíciles de éste de este
juicio